wie schnell dieser krieg endet das hängt
wahrscheinlich vor allem vom russischen
präsidenten putin ab und natürlich der
frage wie viel rückhalt er in der
eigenen bevölkerung hat um diesen
rückhalt zu gewährleisten arbeitet
putins propaganda auf hochtouren und was
das heißt und wie das ganze funktioniert
hat unsere russland korrespondentin
isabel kimmina beobachtet
die nachrichten aus dem russischen
staatsfernsehen berichten dass im gebiet
so hans die bewohner geflohen sein die
unter beschuss der ukrainischen nazis
geraten sein sollen und dieser russische
soldat zeigt seine trophäe von der front
ein ukrainisches fernglas von den
ukrainern einen panzer erbeutet zu haben
sei doppelte freude so der russische
kommentar und dieser soldat berichtet
die ukraine haben den panzer einfach
zurückgelassen mit kompletter bewaffnung
nur siegesmeldungen berichte über
hilfslieferungen und den befreiungskampf
gegen die ukrainische nazis tag für tag
dröhnt das staatsfernsehen seine parolen
in russische wohnzimmer die
nachrichtensendungen wurden seit beginn
der so genannten sonderoperation
verlängert doch viele jüngere russin
lassen sich davon nicht mehr
beeinflussen
ich informiere mich über das internet
über twitter dort finde ich beiträge der
personen denen ich vertrauen
im fernsehen gibt es doch nur propaganda
nun acht jahre lang sind in der ukraine
menschen ums leben gekommen darunter
auch unsere bürger mit unserem mit einem
russischen was das musste man schon
lange bei
allen kanälen die arbeiten
gestern die letzte ausgabe der
unabhängigen tageszeitung nowaja gaseta
die warnungen von der moskauer
medienaufsicht waren deutlich damit
verstummt eine der letzten freien
stimmen in russland
das ist traurig und absolut uneffektiv
das ist im 21 jahrhundert ein kampf mit
mitteln aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert
so hätte zar alexander wahrscheinlich
versucht die presse zu kontrollieren
der kreml sendet seine version der
sogenannten sonderoperation doch es gibt
immer mehr russische journalisten die
nicht mehr mitmachen
kanada kuba war jahrelang
auslandskorrespondentin für einen
russischen sender zu beginn der
sogenannten sonderoperation in der
ukraine hat sie gekündigt im pariser
exil erklärt sie warum
sie die partie jean botti konnten es war
für mich keine frage weiter zu machen
ich konnte das nicht
friedensoperationen
[Musik]
das ist krieg um das ganz klar zu sagen
das ist krieg
jacko war wird wohl erst mal nicht mehr
zurückkehren nach russland und aus dem
essen arbeiten
und in russland läuft derweil putins
propagandamaschinerie weiter mit viel
pathos auf allen kanälen
ja was will putin und zu welchen
kompromissen ist er bereit diese fragen
schweben über den krieg und über den
verhandlungen darüber sprechen wir jetzt
mit dem sicherheitsexperten der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik markus kaim
guten tag
die verhandlungen laufen
was hören sie denn aus den russischen
äußerungen heraus wie ernsthaft lässt
putin da verhandeln also ist hier
bemerkenswert dass die elemente dessen
was eine friedensregelung sein könnte
eine woche nach dem tisch liegen sind im
vorbericht auch angesprochen worden eine
anerkennung der annexion der krim ein
sonderstatus oder die abtrennung der
beiden fonds sogenannten volksrepublik
im südosten des landes eine
neutralisierung des landes militärisch
obergrenzen all das ist eigentlich
bekannt und verfügbar woran es bisher
gemacht hat ist der politische wille und
ich glaube weniger auf ukrainischer
seite da der präsident jahr
kompromissbereitschaft signalisiert
sondern es fehlt nach wie vor eine
bereits vom präsidenten putin von den
weitreichenden russischen fix ihn
abstand zu nehmen im netz lagen hatte
ein anderer weg das wäre der fall
insofern als er davon gesprochen hat
oder die präsidialkanzlei davon
gesprochen hat jetzt würde man sich auf
den süd osten des landes militärisch
konzentrieren da haben wir gedacht das
könnte einen schritt sein die kämpfe
einzulegen davon kann jetzt keine rede
mehr sein weil die kämpfe wieder
ausgebrochen sind also noch mal der ball
liegt im roten feld und milch scheint so
bedauerlich das ist die bereitschaft
noch nicht gegeben zu sein aber schauen
wir mal auf die einzelnen aspekte die
sie auch angesprochen haben also eine
russische kernforderung ist keine nato
mitgliedschaft neutralität haben wir
schon gehört wie könnte das denn dann
konkret auch tatsächlich aussehen wenn
sich die ukraine und da gibt es ja
andeutungen auch für sowas ja also
erwärmen könnte also müsste die
verfassung hin an der ukraine da ist das
festgeschrieben gut das ist ein
technischer hat sie mit der zustimmung
des parlamentes können sie das erreicht
werden dann wie die nächste frage wie
dieser neutralität status gesichert
werden kann da die ukraine bestimmte
vorstellung dass die anti möchte das
gewährleisten sollten man schaut dann in
der regel beste garantie möchte an die
usa großbritannien
deutschland ins spiel gebracht worden
aber genau das wird uns da sind nicht
mal will keine nato staaten ein und aus
zu haben das heißt man müsste einen
länder finden die bereit werden das zu
garantieren gegebenenfalls mit allem
militärischen präsenz vor ort darüber
hinaus wie die frage ob es eine
un-friedenstruppe gibt die für eine
übergangszeit sicherheit gewährleistet
bis beide seiten ihre truppen
zurückgezogen haben auch da können sie
deutschland einen sinnvollen beitrag
leisten aber es ist dasselbe argument
ins feld zu führen ob das in großen auf
zustimmung stößt das bleibt abzuwarten
von russischer seite wird ja auch immer
wieder angesprochen klar und sie auch
schon gesagt die gebiete im osten von
bass die krim welche lösung halten sie
denn dafür wahrscheinlich
also die krim scheint auch aus
ukrainischer perspektive weitgehend
verloren zu sein also ich hab ihn aus
den letzten tagen keine äußeren von
präsidenten ins ging wohin das noch ein
anspruch auf die historische roman man
könnte sich durch das wort denn dass wir
dann jetzt und so gab es eine
übergangsregelung gilt vielleicht ein
unter obhut oder rohre aus sicht der
osze die wichtigsten organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
dass man nicht jetzt status sofort fest
nicht sondern vielleicht der
volksabstimmung unter internationaler
beobachtung durch führt die aber darauf
hinauslaufen würde letztlich auf einen
sonderstatus innerhalb der ukraine mit
einer anlehnung an
ostern das könnte eine übergangsform po
seien in der radikalsten form wäre das
eine zementierung des status quo
eigenstaatlichkeit unter enger anlehnung
an russland müssen wir dann abwarten
vielen dank für ihre einschätzungen dank
an den sicherheitsexperten der stiftung
wissenschaft und politik markus kaim
[Musik]